now as the new Conservative government
gears up for its first cabinet meeting
the Labour Party shadow cabinet remains
kind of half for both the former shadow
welfare secretary owen smith and the
former shadow business secretary Angela
Eagle are campaigning now to become the
new labour leader trying to replace
Jeremy Corbyn well Angela Eagle joins me
now in a very good morning team is Eagle
this issue announced myths been saying
it really there should be one of you
takes on Jeremy Corbyn you're going to
split the vote what's your response to
that well none of us want to be here but
we are here because Jeremy's failed to
connect with labour voters outside much
less talk to other voters and so with a
early general election still beckoning I
think we have to try to replace the
Labour leader and that's why I put my
name forward because I think I'm the
best candidate to do this job and I
think I'd be a good Prime Minister so
we're going to be at the Labour hustings
tomorrow and we'll see what colleagues
think nominations open at seven o'clock
I mean it's not a way of saying yes
you've got to agree be better if one of
you takes on Jeremy Corbyn you know how
difficult it's going to be to try and
get him out as as you want you're saying
it there should be one candidate and it
should be me I I'm not getting involved
in any of that at the moment I'm putting
my pitch both to that my labour
colleagues in the hustings but also to
the party as a whole we do need a change
of leadership I think Jeremy's opened up
the party to new thinking we've got a
lot of new members which is extremely
welcome but he isn't a leader and he's
not connecting with the British people
so now we need to make a change and get
somebody to take that forward and yes I
wouldn't have bought myself forward if I
didn't think that I would be the person
the best person as a working class woman
from the North who understands how
difficult it is for working-class kids
to get on because my mom and dad my mom
was a seamstress she couldn't get on she
was very clever didn't get the
opportunities that Labour government
made sure I had and when she went to try
and get a job she was told she couldn't
work in an office because she was a
factory girl we don't want that kind of
society but just back to the very I mean
that you know the mechanism of getting
rid of Jeremy Corbyn that's what you
want to see it would be better would it
not if there's just one
garnering those as antique Corbin votes
you're in dangerous spreading yourself
let me let me turn because this is John
mcdonnell/the shadow chancellor no key
lieutenant of jeremy corbyn he's just
been on saying he really wants to see
you stay on the ballot paper and Owen
Smith in other words the Corbin Easter's
if we may term than that want to see the
vote split well we don't we don't know
what what will happen and what the peel
peel decide I'm concentrating on putting
my pitch to them I don't want to be
involved in some backroom deal at the
moment before nominations have even
opened you're anticipating things a bit
too much let's put our arguments to the
country and let's remember do we want
another all male leadership team I'm a
woman I'm a strong working-class roots I
understand the areas of our country that
have been so alienated that they voted
to leave and are now being threatened
with yet another economic hit as a
result of the challenges faced by brexit
when they've already borne the brunt of
Tory austerity but what about this idea
again coming from Owen Smith you
mentioned that the hustings there that
whoever has the most support at the
hustings they should be the one that
goes forward well look let's just wait
and see what happens I don't want to get
involved in this studio before we've
even had the hostage don't be logical
wouldn't any of you that make sure you
like rim dated that if there's one of
you one of the candidates gets seems to
have more support that they take the
standard fault well look we have we have
an alternative vote system and so I
don't think that's clear at all but
let's see what the PLP do I'm putting a
pitch because of my experience in
Parliament whenever I've been asked to
step up I have look at how I wiped the
floor with George Osborne at prime
minister's questions when i was when i
was in there for jeremy deputizing I
think I'm someone who's got a lot of
experience and a lot to offer the Labour
Party in these very difficult times but
are you a bit tainted just by being in
the parliamentary Labour Party for so
long well we've got this from you know a
source who doesn't wanna see Jeremy
Corbyn stay on saying that Angela Eagle
has surrounded herself with too many
Blairites and in you and in the past
week have a growing sense of entitlement
about yourself I have never had a sense
of entitlement I've had to fight for
everything I've got in my life as
somebody who came from very humble
beginnings with my dad being a printer
and my mom a seamstress and I'm in
nobody's camp my camp is the Labour
Party because the Labour Party is the
only vehicle for giving working-class
children like I was when I was growing
up proper opportunities in life that's
been my mission in politics anyone who
knows me knows that I'm my own woman hmm
but its an albatross around your neck is
nothing voting in Parliament alongside
Tony Blair and many others it must be
said to invade Iraq can I just say I was
sacked by Tony Blair and I was the only
member of the Tribune executive when we
have that leadership election you didn't
nominate Tony Blair I actually nominated
Margaret Beckett because I felt we
needed to have a woman leader I'm very
straightforward I say what I think I'm
not in any camp and now is the time when
we don't need to be thinking about those
old Blair right brownout Corbin astir
country so we bring us within your party
you saw what happened after shield car
listen we need to be looking forwards
our country faces huge challenges at the
moment with the shock of breaks it and
it's our communities in the north of
England that will suffer the most on top
of the austerity cuts that they've been
hit with already if we don't do our job
as a progressive Labour Party can I just
ask you finally you know this issue of
the 10 of the tone of the debate how
nasty it's getting in some areas you
know on social media and indeed
face-to-face you just heard John
McDonald they're saying yet again he
wants it to be respectful and polite
then he goes out one night and uses the
f word do you believe in well I launched
a hashtag called keep it comradely
because I think it's really important
that we debate ideas there has been a
nasty poisonous tone I've never had so
much misogyny or homophobia thrown at me
since I studies any [ __ ] is really
trying to clamp down on they they need
to ensure that it stops and they can
call it to stop more effectively and I
think the people who are party members
if their party members that are doing
that they need to be expelled okay
Angela Eagle very good see thank you
very much experiment